según un estudio que se publicó en el
año 2016 que realizó la
en el instituto peterson de economía
junto con igual las empresas que tienen
más mujeres en cargos de liderazgo son
más rentables e incluso se estudio dice
que son un 50% más rentable
cuando yo conocí el resultado de estos
estudios con otras colegas mías que
trabajábamos en el mundo corporativo
ustedes pueden imaginar cómo saltamos en
un plan y dijimos bien por fin nos van a
escuchar parece que si no hemos logrado
que haya más mujeres en cargos de alta
dirección por un tema de que es lo
correcto a lo menos lo van a hacer
porque un buen negocio
porque se van a dar cuenta que les puede
ir mejor en su empresa pero en esta
reflexión y cuando estábamos conversando
respecto de esto yo me acordé de una
reflexión en la que había estado dando
vuelta hace muchos años atrás por alguna
razón lo había abandonado porque después
en el tiempo me dediqué a trabajar en
todas aquellas cosas que desde el mundo
de los femeninos de la incorporación de
la mujer al mundo del trabajo han sido
nuestras últimas luchas a entender y
discutir respecto a la ley de cuotas las
empresas en cómo tratar el tema de las
leyes de posnatal de la sociedad
conyugal en chile a trabajar aprender e
instalar la discusión al interior de las
organizaciones sobre la teoría de sesgo
inconsciente y también a trabajar
muchísimo por el empoderamiento en las
mujeres para que se atrevan en el mundo
del emprendimiento
pero cuando vi este mes y estábamos en
esta conversación me acordé de algo en
lo que yo había pensar que capaz tenga
que ver con lo esencial con la razón de
fondo de porque realmente las
organizaciones necesitan tener más
mujeres en cargos de liderazgo
y esa reflexión tenía que ver con esta
pregunta
que yo me hice hace muchos años atrás
cuál es la ventaja competitiva o existe
de verdad una ventaja competitiva de ser
mujer cuando eres líder
y retomé esa reflexión y es lo que les
quiero compartir hoy día a partir de mi
experiencia personal
esa que era yo cuando era pequeña
usted podrán imaginar medio súper
femenina con la tutu así como la cosa de
la niñita que uno siempre hubiese soñado
bueno bailar ballet dulce tímida voz
sencilla cariñosa todo el mundo decía
que yo era un encanto todo el mundo me
quería cuidar porque yo no molestaba a
nadie
mis papás me podían dejar con todas las
personas
ahora lo increíble es que yo nace en una
familia donde ese es mi padre era un
hombre que toda la vida me repitió que
tenía que estudiar que tenía que ser
profesional
y lo decía a veces de una manera
bastante brutal porque me decía yo no
quiero que mi hija mayor sea una
mantenida de un hombre
y eso hizo de alguna forma
que yo me dedicara de verdad en lo que
mi padre quería de mí fui súper aplicada
en el colegio siempre la mejor alumna
del colegio y por supuesto cuando llegó
la hora de elegir una carrera en la
universidad había que elegir una carrera
donde el papá se sintiera orgulloso de
su hija aplicada entonces terminé
estudiando ingeniería
en el paso de estar en la universidad y
de vivir con esta cosa de ser perfecta
de ser siempre la primera empecé a
descubrir primero en la universidad
después llegué a trabajar al mundo
corporativo que pareciera que para que
te fuera bien los códigos que había que
usar no eran los de una mujer en la
universidad aprendí que había cola
fuerte
que la emoción es decir lo que uno
sentía podía ser tomado como símbolo de
débil ya que palabras como cariños
sueños
convicciones en las conversaciones de
negocios y también cuando estudiábamos
en la universidad como que la gente te
quedaba mirando mayoría hombre como
diciendo donde cree ella que está
porque aquí estamos hablando cosas
serias
y me fue acostumbrando a eso y me
dediqué
en el trabajo hacer una profesional
super racional siempre muy aplicada muy
estudiosa y me fue bien hasta que un día
se me dio la oportunidad de poder asumir
la dirección del acompañante y otra baja
asumir el cargo de gerente general yo
estaba súper asustado porque antes había
habido un gerente general hombre obvio
muy
inteligente
y una amiga un día me dijo solo mejor
que yo creo que tú debería estar un poco
más relajada y yo te puedo dar un solo
consejo creo que tienes que mantener
todo lo que has hecho hasta ahora eso
siempre aplica a mí siempre me dijieron
que era muy mate a no siempre aplica
estudiosa pero hay una cosa más si
quieres que te vaya bien en tu nuevo rol
creo que dejaría que el mundo viera
quién es la soledad basta
y que seas tú cariñosa con tu tono de
voz no con ese que pones cuando trabaja
y hace posiciones sino que con tu tono
de voz con tus emociones con tu forma de
hablar o sea que sea esto
me dejó pensando mi amiga y ese día me
dio muchas vueltas muchas cosas en la
cabeza y en la mañana me levanté seguía
dando vueltas en eso y me paró al frente
del espejo y de repente vi esto
y me horroricé en eso voy a convertido
en la mujer hombre que es la única forma
en que te puede ir bien que hablaba
fuerte que no habla de sus emociones que
era muy racional para todas sus
decisiones en el mundo del trabajo
y decidí que no quería seguir siendo
y decidí enfrentar mi futuro laboral
ahora desde lo femenino y fue en el año
2010 que a propósito de un premio que me
gané siendo hombre asno
yo creo que precisamente pues por
vuestras la autenticidad yo creo que por
fin fui capaz de decir eso públicamente
y en una entrevista que me hicieron en
una revista muy muy importante del mundo
económico acá en chile no dije esto que
está ahí no dije que efectivamente
el liderazgo de una mujer es un camino
super complejo no
y que tú constantemente te ves tentada a
ocupar que para ocupar los espacios de
poder y te vaya bien
y empiece a entrar en el juego de los
códigos masculinos
y yo me resistió el último tiempo en mi
vida eso y hoy día me eslogan o les
gusta bien y si no también
así soy yo
pero saben lo que va a pasar en este
tiempo que esta cosa a la que yo llegué
por intuición por convicción por
sentirme cómoda una cosa maravillosa que
ha ocurrido es que ha empezado a existir
evidencias estudios que demuestran que
esto que yo descubrí de casualidad en
realidad es verdad las organizaciones y
que probablemente explica harto de por
qué ese estudio que les mencioné al
principio muestra que las empresas que
tienen más participación de mujeres en
cargos de liderazgo tienen mejores
resultados de negocio también al final
del día
ya en la universidad de queensland hizo
cierta investigaciones donde decía que
la mujer en general creíamos creencias
que adoptar códigos masculinos nos da
una mejor probabilidad de superar todas
las dificultades de la carrera
profesional y tener éxito pero lo
curioso que en esos mismos estudios
demostraban el tremendo valor agregado
que tienen las características propias
de las mujeres en la generación de
equipos de trabajo de alto desempeño
yo creo que revisemos algunas para que
vayamos a los concretos y empezamos a
darnos cuenta que estos son cosas
concretas y hay evidencias concretas hay
cinco cosas
que unos buscan los estudios y van
rescatando como elementos centrales
donde las mujeres hacen diferencias que
combinadas con las capacidades de los
hombres pueden hacer que a una empresa
le vaya muy bien
primero el estilo de liderazgo
en general las mujeres tenemos un estilo
de liderazgo que está mucho más
inclinado hacia el acompañamiento la
tutoría el coach mientras que los
hombres son mucho más orientados al
control de la supervisión ambas
características son necesarias en una
organización y las organizaciones que
son lo suficientemente inteligentes lo
que hacen es poner hombres y mujeres a
trabajar juntos y mezclado en distintos
roles dentro de la organización
esto que hoy día ya está estudiado
yo lo vi bien que experiencia propia
a mí siempre me gustó tener un partner
hombre que pusiera precisamente todo
aquello que yo no tenía yo soy muy
emocional necesito a alguien al lado mío
y de repente me controlé un poquito para
no desbordar me y yo creo que eso formó
parte también de las cosas que han
venido resultando y han ido
convirtiéndose en éxitos después mi
trabajo entonces lo primero el estilo de
liderazgo de las mujeres es un tremendo
aporte a las organizaciones cuando está
bien combinado con las características
propias de los hombres lo segundo no
tiene que ver con esto que llamamos el
pensamiento holístico
las mujeres tenemos la capacidad
probablemente porque nos toca cumplir
múltiples roles en la vía de mirar el
360 grados mucho más desarrollada que
los jóvenes supongo que varios de
ustedes han visto este vídeo en donde se
muestra como el cerebro de la mujer como
el del hombre no el hombre son puras
cajitas separadas y la de las mujeres
son un montón de cosas que se
interconectan esa capacidad que nos
permite no quedarnos solamente
obsesionados con los resultados de corto
plazo sino que ser capaz de mirar más
allá de mirar el futuro y entender que
estos logros de corto plazo son pasos
para un fin que es más grande es una
tremenda virtud que tienen las mujeres
los hombres son más orientados al hacer
se necesita también eso en una
organización
nosotros tenemos más la capacidad de
soñar y proyectar hacia el futuro
por lo tanto otro elemento que aportan
las características de las mujeres a la
organización es esta capacidad de mirar
el futuro y seña
lo de cero
el engagement
hoy día en una época donde las empresas
lo que necesitan y lo que estamos
hablando todo que las empresas que
tienen éxito una de las cosas que tienen
que hacer es generar sentido propósito
esto que llamamos el compromiso que
finalmente viene desde el corazón porque
el compromiso no ocurre acá ocurre acá
bueno las mujeres tenemos una tremenda
virtud para hacer esto
probablemente porque la empatía es algo
que nace en nuestra genética tendrá que
ver probablemente con las tareas de
cuidado sexualmente yo digo que a lo
mejor si esta capacidad y esta facilidad
para ponerse permanentemente en el lugar
del otro
pensar y sentir
como siente el otro y a partir de ahí
construir confianza y generar afectos
dentro de las organizaciones
por lo tanto cuando las mujeres están
repartidas en igual proporción opuesta
en los lugares de alta dirección le dan
un poquito más de humanidad a la
organización
y eso hace que tanto sus empleados como
sus clientes o su otro stakeholder
genera una relación con la organización
que va mucho más allá de lo
transaccional que también es aquí es de
lo emocional
siguiendo todo lo que consumimos
para que después salgan todas las
mujeres de aquí diciendo necesitan a
todos los grandes empresarios y leiden
solo necesitan contratar mujeres
un cuarto elemento tiene que ver con la
innovación yo creo que tiene que ver con
lo mismo que hemos hablado pensamiento
holístico esta capacidad de mirar más
allá es curioso que a pesar de las
mujeres tener todas estas
características que son tan útiles para
los procesos de organiza de innovación
dentro de las organizaciones nos
figuramos dentro de las que promovimos
inventamos o fundamos la grandes
compañía innovadora en el mundo supongo
que será porque vamos un poquito más
atrás en el mundo del stem y de estudiar
carreras de tecnologías vinculadas con
la ciencia pero también algo deben haber
entendido esto si o cuando el sido de
facebook pone de brazo derecho su
compañía a una mujer
algo habrá entendido que aporta el
proceso de innovación
y por último la capacidad que tienen las
mujeres de contribuir a crear dentro de
las organizaciones tremendos y
saludables climas laborales
probablemente esto también tiene que ver
con la empatía con el cariño con la
facilidad no es más natural expresar las
emociones y cuando uno construye un
equipo de trabajo una de las cosas que
clave en el clima laboral en este tipo
de trabajo es que uno se sienta libre de
poder decir lo que siente
y parece que nosotros nos sale mucho más
natural puede propiciar ese tipo de
ambiente
en resumen parece que tenemos hartas
cosas que son muy propias de nuestro
sexo y nuestro género que pueden hacer
un tremendo aporte para las
organizaciones entonces no las
escondemos
usemos la multi mola yo hice eso durante
toda mi vida laboral y pienso seguir
haciéndolo
me atreví a hablar de un tipo de
liderazgo al que ella me firme cariñoso
y a construir un modelo que fuera
implementado en toda la organización que
yo dirigía me atreví a hablar de
felicidad organizacional al interior de
la empresa a pesar del bullying que me
hicieron en el mundo corporativo por
hablar de esa locura hicimos un modelo
hoy día un bien público se escriben
libros de felicia organizacional y se
dictan magíster de felicidad
organizacional y eso se le ocurrió a dos
mujeres porque no fui yo sola fue con
una colega mire en mi empresa
nos atrevimos además de decir de que de
verdad en el trabajo la única diferencia
que había entre en este caso yo que era
la cia y un colaborador mío era el rol y
la responsabilidad que teníamos dentro
de la organización porque en términos de
personas éramos iguales
y sabes lo que pasó la compañía que yo
dirigí llegó a ser y sigue siendo la
número uno su industria ha sido tres
veces elegida la mejor empresa para
trabajar en chile y ha estado tres veces
dentro de las mejores de latinoamérica y
lo más hermoso me pasó a mí en términos
personales aparte de haber dejado una
tremenda compañía instalada ahí que el
día que decidí retirarme a esa compañía
lo que escuche una y otra vez de cada
una de las personas que se despidieron
de mí fue que me iban a extrañar
muchísimo porque me creían y porque me
querían
y para mí me di por pagada era todo el
éxito que yo esperaba tener cuando mi
papá me dijo tú tienes que ser
entonces mujeres del mundo
ser mujer y puede ser una ventaja
competitiva no saquen lo mejor de cada
una no traten de parecerse a los hombres
los hombres y las mujeres necesitan
trabajar juntos y si el cosmos o dios o
la deidad creó el 50 por ciento de
hombre y el 50 por ciento de mujeres
supongo que será porque ambos son
necesarios
entonces siéntase orgullosa y llegue
mañana a pedir un trabajo y a decir te
traigo al menos cinco ventajas
competitivas para el éxito de tu
compañía muchas gracias
[Aplausos]